[Norvig] Here's a definition of card_ranks that's almost right.
We say what card_ranks does. It returns a list of the ranks sorted with higher first.
We pulled the ranks out of the cards,
so here we're iterating over the cards and we're having 2 values: the rank and the suit.
And what this is doing is saying each card is a 2 value element,
and we can break down those 2 elements into the first and second,
the one that has rank 0 and rank 1 or index 0 and index 1.
And so we're saying a card consists of a rank and a suit,
and we're only going to collect up the ranks and make that into a list.
So ranks is the list of ranks, then we sorted it and we said we want to reverse sort
so that the higher comes first rather than the lower, and then we return the ranks.
This is almost right, but the problem is if we just pull out the rank of each card as is,
then the rank T for 10 is the highest because T comes alphabetically after A
and Q and all the other cards. But we don't want that.
Instead we want 10 to map to the number 10 and J to the number 11 and so on.
So we're going to have to come up with a way of fixing that,
taking these letters that we pulled out of the cards
and mapping them into an integer in the correct way.
See if you can fix this definition of card_ranks
to correctly return a list of numbers, not a list of characters.